as I said we're gonna be doing powers of
functions today and we're going to get
some grass when you start over gets
grass enough to zoom it and very quickly
we're going to go into underground as
has been the theme ok so how does it
functions when you see the word powers
we're thinking about taking a function
right y equals f of X and then raising
the whole f of X piece to some kind of
power strictly speaking so the classical
ones that we have a look at the most
important ones the most important part
of our and to those are the most common
ones you can see them all the time when
you take square root of function when
you square a function there are some
quite predictable features that are
important for us one have a look at this
so that's the first thing however there
is a slight variant on this with which
also comes up somewhat frequently which
is this right now do you remember what
we were doing reflections and forefinger
and translations and I only we'd say oh
yeah y equals like say the absolute
value of affairs rather than we know
what happens to a line like that okay
turn to that Bell TV well this is the
same kind of thing when you flip over
the other side what effect is that okay
so we're going to explore that a little
bit now to begin with before we love all
these unfamiliar functions we've got to
look at that functions with most
familiar with so what we're going to do
is we're going to start by considering
the simplest function that does
something even vaguely interesting when
you take square root when you square it
which is simply like was X okay now
therefore when you raise it to the
patterns that I'm interested in that's
obviously going to give you y equals the
square root of x and then it's also
going to give you the parabola now you
know exactly what all of these look like
but there's a very important lessons to
drawn from these so we're going to draw
these three graphs these two together
and these two together on the same set
of axioms okay so just take a couple of
minutes draw these up there have to be a
big or beautiful because they're quite
simple graphs as you
alright so we've got our two sets of
axes what I'd like on each set of axes
is the white with X line and then in
addition to that over here we'll do red
x over here we'll do x squared so will
superimpose that'll top and then we'll
notice something's okay all right so why
do we have a look at these now like I
said we're gonna look at ease because
we're very familiar with them but I want
to draw your attention to some things
that we don't tend to have to worry
about because we're so familiar with
them we don't think about relaxed in
relation to X because we know exactly
what really looks like and we don't
think about x squared in relation to X
very much because we know what x squared
looks like okay so we're going to notice
lots and lots of little features about
this um we're going to look and look and
look and see what we notice okay so
first thing let's begin with rude x I
immediately notice the y equals x has no
domain restriction but lakers reacts
does have a domain restriction and that
is because okay yeah i heard a few
different phrases but I'm wonderful
because I sort of heard as the edges I
heard coming back from the room are the
same kinds of answers that if year three
kit will say but I say why can't you do
through take away five and they'll say
well cuz power you know you guys are
essential to students you know about
square roots and things like a square
roots you have better more specific
accurate language to explain why on this
graph let me give you a clue this graph
I can't have all values why not there's
no
okay I have no I'm no imaginary units on
this that's a real set of real numbers
that's a set of real numbers now you
guys know that the square roots of
negative numbers do exist they're just
not on this graph right there on the
Argan plane and I don't have the audio
claim here if I do have it I guess it
would come out like this would be the
real part and I guess because this axis
has been occupied by another realtor but
i guess the battery power would come out
this way okay so if you want to imagine
the are the imaginary axis don't have it
sort of extending out this way from the
board okay so what you're used to
looking at I can't draw on here because
I don't have any access / rather over
here where I do have just real numbers
I've got nothing okay so that's that
that's fine what else you want to tell
me about this root X particularly in
relation to why it was it here things
you want to tell me what okay so there's
a point of intersection right there it
is in fact it's so important we should
say what it is it's 11 now why is that
the intersection is that the
intersection because because the square
root of one is itself one now that's not
the only put interview isn't what's the
other one and that's also important so
we should put that it as well because
there are only two numbers in existence
whose square roots are themselves and
they are 0 1 okay so that's good that's
the first important thing division one
else here you tell me about this graph
what else do you observe
yeah very is on the positive side okay
so wait when you say the positive side
do you mean like this way or this way we
play on the bus yeah yeah okay so that's
two things fit for 141 we've got the
first thing before which is the domain
restriction in that here if you're only
playing in the real number field then
you can't take square roots of negative
values of x okay but that doesn't
explain why I'm up here why I've only
got positive values of Y and you want to
give me a suggestion there's an
important word here that starts with the
letter P I don't know if you remember
act has to do it easily it's the
principal square root very good right
there are two square roots for real
numbers but I'm only drawing the
principal square root I could drawing
this other side down here but that look
in your relationship on a function so we
leave it off okay all right anything
else you want to notice yeah excellent
square of x is greater than f of X and
when x is grid
y equals there yeah very good okay this
is a really crucial point in fact maybe
in terms of graphing all these other
guys that we're going to shortly maybe
the most important point this is uptown
change as a vertical change the abscissa
changes right no people what are the
changes now then how does it change well
it's actually easier to think on the
right hand side first when x is bigger
than one the square root of any number
is going to be smaller than that number
square root of sixty-four eights for a
49-7 you always getting a smaller number
so long as you're on this side all right
because that we multiply by something
you're going to get bigger okay but when
you go in between here from not 21 the
square of your number is bigger than the
number yeah like for example the square
root of a quarter so number that when
you multiply it by itself gives your
quarter is of course uh-huh and a half
is bigger than caught up okay now this
is very important when you are armed
when you were drawing graphs like this
right right one of the things we noticed
was that wherever y equals zero is a
really critical point because when you
flip it vertically all those zeroes they
stayed safe yeah so for example some
people books like this would become
something looks like this right so zeros
are important okay but whenever you're
dealing with these guys y equals zero is
not only the important line y equals one
is also an important line anytime you
intersect with that you know you're
behaving above or below that line okay
so it's really really more okay one more
thing to notice for me you've got this
up and down business that we've just
noticed what about what's happening here
what what is going on here what's the
gradient is point don't know the great
news at that point at the origin
hmm its knowledge now there are white
mr. square badge doesn't have a gradient
at the origin and you can verify that in
a variety of ways I'm for example you
could just differentiate the dumping
right what is the do video oh you're
going to breathe up our out the front
which is a heart and then you're going
to reduce the pad by one the power is
heart before and now it's negative a
half so actually that means it's going
to be done here okay so you go ahead and
you try to slot in x equals zero find
out what's happening in the argument and
of course you get a nonsensical result
okay it's no great in here because if
you think about rise over run how far is
it running of funds are running the
interest is not running anywhere it's if
you were to draw a tangent here it would
be actually I've already to an attention
there do you notice that it's the y-axis
there's no greater that's really weird
it's really weird and that's important
because anytime you get something like
this you're going to get your gradient
becoming well under fire ok keep as you
like